[Music]
what about rugby is rugby its rugby huge
in Austria like a rugby league I follow
mainly fellow rugby league because right
now people watching world series that's
big baseball and people of course follow
football here is is insane rugby what
are the team's names do they have names
like the names of our teams they know no
science that it's been around for a
while my team's the eels
you know I fear the eels I don't think
of the eels this being appears they've
been bitten by Neil oh I could tell you
it would hurt you ever tried to catch an
eel they're slippery yeah yeah you're
not convincing me okay but not on a
rugby field after I think me versus an
eel on a rugby field I'd have the
advantage this the Rabbitohs yeah that's
right that's Russell Russell Crowe's is
called the Rabbitohs Rabbitohs rabbit us
a rabbit oh well it's as my son Harry
calls it the rabbit toes right but it's
called the Rabbitohs how is that fear I
mean you can at least say the ears ding
what are the rabbits do they multiply
[Laughter]
yeah what a fierce line up this slippery
eel and the cuddly bunny next up bunny
you can't wait to check that out before
you go any Halloween plans I have an ass
cuz I'm God I know I never dress up for
Halloween but this is no I never do I
actually never dress up as for Halloween
it's not really big on Halloween no no I
mean I do I probably would if I grow up
with it but I didn't grow up with it so
to me it's sort of like you know you
kids go out there and just Fistful of
candy and they get all wide and run
around and right it's like giving kind
of smack to junkies and then there's
always the the you know the random sort
of middle-aged guy that shows up way too
late when no one else is
trick-or-treating anything he's got
cornrows and an orange face
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's where I met you before I know
yeah yeah and your candy sucks by the
way some weird Australian candy with
Vegemite in it I remember this